JENNY BROWN: Today,
we're talking
about I/O, 2022 summits, role
certifications, and a shift
in shopping habits that
might surprise you.
I'm Jenny Brown, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Google I/O is back
May 11 through 12,
and all content is virtual
and free for everyone.
Connect with developers
from around the world
for thoughtful discussions,
learn from Google experts,
and get a first look at our
latest developer products.
This year, the program looks
a little bit different.
You can catch all keynotes,
product announcements,
and Learning Lab
content on day 1.
And then come back for day 2,
when all technical sessions
will be available on demand.
Register and check out
the program at io.google.
Our 2022 Google Cloud Summit
Series is in full swing,
and you can be among the first
to learn about new solutions
across data, machine learning,
collaboration, security,
sustainability, and more.
We've got several events in
the upcoming weeks where you'll
hear from experts, explore
customer perspectives,
engage with interactive
demos, and gain
valuable insights to help
you accelerate your business
transformation.
Be sure to bookmark the
Google Cloud Summit Series
website to easily find
updates as news develops.
We've rebranded the Professional
Collaboration Engineer
Certification to the
Professional Google Workspace
Administrator Certification,
and we've updated
the relevant learning path.
Check out the blog for more
details and an interview
about the Google Workspace
administrator role
and how demand and
preparation for this skill set
has changed over the years.
Shifting work habits, more
online shopping options,
rising inflation, and stretched
supply chains are just a few
of the factors making it
harder to discern what's
top of mind for shoppers today.
And while price
unsurprisingly continues
to be a major
consideration in purchases,
the average shopper
is increasingly
paying close attention to the
values of consumer goods brands
and how eco-friendly their
products and practices are.
Head to the blog to learn
more from this research
and how brands can adapt.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us,
and we'll see you in the Cloud.